SARAH THOMSON: So I'm
going to be starting you
off here with some of the
latest and greatest tools
that we have.
So I'm going to take you
on a bit of a journey here.
Bear with me.
This is going to be
fast and furious,
and I'm going to be throwing
a lot of information at you.
And a lot of it's going
to be quite high-level.
The idea here is to kind
of get this on your radar
if you've not heard
of these tools yet.
Some of them maybe
you're already using.
And we'll be talking a little
bit about best practices
as well.
But essentially, envision
this being a buffet.
I'm going to set up a variety
of dishes and tasty treats.
Some of it you might like;
some of it you might not like.
And it's completely up
to you as to what you
think will benefit
you and your team
to make the best game
you possibly can.
So here, you'll see we're going
to be talking about pre-launch,
launch window, and post-launch.
So first, we'll dive
into pre-launch.
And this is where I'm going to
be spending quite a bit of time
because, really,
here's where you
are going to be forging in the
fire to create your best game.
This is where you're going
to be doing a lot of testing.
You're going to be iterating a
lot, making a lot of mistakes,
learning from it.
So here's the
opening mantra that I
wanted to throw at you, which
is test earlier, test wider,
test better.
So maybe the first and the
third feel comfortable for you
as a small team.
Maybe the middle
one not so much.
So this is something that we've
been advocating for for teams
of all kinds of sizes because
we've built a lot of tools
that allow you to do this.
And there's a benefit to test
wider, which, hopefully, means
you're doing a lot
of problem-solving
and eliminating those unforeseen
issues that pop up once you
have launched, and, perhaps,
you didn't test as widely
as you thought you did.
So first let us start
with internal testing.
This is a really great
way and a great tool
to use for your team.
This is team testing.
This allows you to
launch a new build
within seconds versus hours.
Very fast iteration, you're
getting different builds
out several times
a day, if needed,
if you're doing quick
fixes, and you're really
addressing that
foundational stuff early on.
Next, we move to closed testing.
This is where you
broaden out a little bit
to maybe your highest engaged
users, those who are really
excited about your game, maybe
friends and family as well.
And here's where you can
start getting a sense of what
your gamers are telling you.
This is very
foundational feedback
that you're getting initially
from a very small set
of your user base.
This is also known
as closed beta.
So here we have our friends
at Butterscotch Shenanigans
talking about their experience.
And essentially, this
has been crucial for them
in targeting those
bugs and those
crashes so that they're
launching a product
that they feel confident about.
They feel good about it.
And the tool really
facilitates that for them.
What this also
does for you is it
allows you to start
getting a little bit more
of that wider testing in there,
a wider variety of users.
So you're getting a
spectrum of feedback.
Closed testing also is
great because it gives you
a chance to not have any
kind of ratings effects.
So if you're
wanting to take big,
bold moves around
feature testing--
one of your team members
has a crazy idea,
and you want to
throw it out there
into the wild within
this particular audience,
this is a great
place to do that.
So who's heard of early access?
Has anyone been part of the
Early Access program on Play?
Great.
OK.
So this is our official program.
This is a program that you
actually have to apply for.
And this is open beta
that is officialized
as a program on Play.
And the difference
between open beta,
which I'll be speaking
to right after this,
which anyone can do, you
don't have to apply for--
is that this gives you an
opportunity to actually
be featured on the store.
And the next slide will
also talk about what
that collection looks like.
So when you actually apply for
this, and if you get accepted,
you are then merchandised on
the store as an unreleased game.
So this is a great way to
get visibility and start
funneling users for free
into your game-- really
great for indies.
I know a lot of indies
just don't have UA budget,
or it's very
minimal, or you have
to be very strategic
about where you use that.
And this is an opportunity
to give you that leg up
and get that visibility.
The important caveat around this
program is that your APK cannot
have been in production at
all in any country if you want
to actually be a
part of Early Access.
So they're always
experimenting to see
how they can get as many gamers
into your game as possible.
But at the end of
the day, you're
getting really great
visibility around that.
And so here's our Iron Horse,
who we have with us today,
who was talking about how
instrumental this has been
to launching their games,
especially, in that beta phase
and getting users
into their games early
and how incredibly useful
that's been for them.
And Mike will
actually be speaking
on a panel a little
bit later today.
And I'm sure this topic
will come up as well.
And feel free to ask him
questions about that.
And so this is open beta.
So let's say you spend
some time in Early Access.
You got some really
great visibility.
You're not quite ready
to fully launch yet.
This is an opportunity
to then move over
into that next
phase of open beta.
And again, this is where you
can have a lot of freedom
to still be doing testing to
get a sense of what's working
and what isn't and not have
any consequences of ratings.
So the thing about
Google Play is
that, if you have a rating
at this stage in the game,
it does stick with your
overall average rating.
So it's really
important to iterate
as much as you can before full
launch when the ratings really
do start mattering.
And this gives
you an opportunity
to make those mistakes and not
have those consequences show up
on your user rating.
OK.
So to sum it all
up, here are all
of those phases I mentioned.
You start off very fast, very
iterative with your own team,
working out the fundamentals.
Then you can broaden
it out a little bit,
closed testing with a very
small group of your user base,
get some really good
detailed feedback.
Then you can move into
Early Access if you wish.
Start getting some
visibility around your game
in that unreleased phase.
And then, lastly,
you can transition
into open beta or open
testing and really
broaden it out as
wide as you can
before you go into full launch.
So one little thought
starter that I'd
like to plant in your mind
is continuously evaluate
your process.
Teams of all sizes--
this is not just
an indie thing--
we've seen large teams
get stuck in ruts
around how they develop games.
And I think it's really
easy to get into a pattern
and get into a habit, and
it becomes solidified.
As we all know, mobile is
still moving stupid fast.
There's a lot of change.
There's a lot of
volatility in this market.
And Android, Google is always
launching new tools for you.
So always look at how you can
optimize your own process.
Because, at the end of the
day, this is your opportunity
to make the best game you can.
And I want you to be
successful and Play
wants you to be successful.
OK.
So now we're in launch window.
So here are a couple of things
I'll be touching on quickly
that will give you some thought
starters and things to check
out maybe, I'd say, one or
two months before your launch.
So maybe we can make you 100%
confident, maybe not 100%,
maybe way more confident than
you have been in the past.
I remember what that
was like to launch games
and how nerve-wracking that
was and watching user ratings
and watching the stats
from the Play Console
or from the backend of whatever
platform you've launched on.
So hopefully, we can
minimize those stress points.
Here we are-- device catalog
and pre-registration.
Does anyone use
the device catalog?
Raise your hands.
A couple.
Oh, great.
This is an opportunity
for you all.
This is exciting.
OK.
So one of the great
things about Android
is that you can
reach a lot of users.
We have a huge variety
of devices out there.
The reach is incredible.
Now, we all know the
downside of that.
Fragmentation can be
a bit of a nightmare,
especially, when you
are very small team.
It's very intimidating,
and it's quite unruly.
So I encourage you all to
check out the device catalog
because what this is
is knowledge for you.
And knowledge is power.
And essentially, what
the device catalog is is,
within the Play Console--
this is something
each and every one
of you can access from
your own Play Console--
is you can see a
list of thousands
of devices, Android devices,
with a ton of really great
granular detail.
And I'll show you an example
of what that screen looks like.
And this is here because
we want to really reduce
those pain points of the
fragmentation of the ecosystem.
But also, too, I would
challenge you all
to try to support as
many devices as you can.
One thing that I hear that is
fairly common across indies
is that there's this
really great desire
to want to get your game into
as many players hands, which
I think is a really
beautiful thing to achieve.
And I would hate to see you
limited by that, by devices.
And of course, that's going
to depend on the game, right?
There's certain
games that you just
can't run on certain devices.
So start wide.
Start as broad as you
can, which will feel very
scary and counterintuitive.
But really, what you're able to
do then is, once you launch--
or once you have your game
running on as many devices
as you can, you can then go into
the Detail pages, right here.
And you can see things like
RAM, screen size, density--
all sorts of really
great details
around the specs
of those devices.
And icing on top of that
is you can see, actually,
how your game is
doing from a sales
perspective on those devices.
And it's interesting to hear
how many developers that
are using the device catalog are
very surprised by how there's
some segment or
grouping of devices
that they just weren't
aware of or had no idea
that their game was
performing quite well
and that there was an
opportunity for them
to optimize and make
that experience better.
So this is your
chance to, not only
serve as many gamers
as you possibly can
in the rich ecosystem
that is Android,
but also gives you
the power to provide
a consistent and fun
experience no matter
which device they're on.
So just to recap a
little bit about that.
Try to support as many
devices as you can.
Use that knowledge.
Empower yourself with
everything the device catalog
is giving you.
And then really laser
cut out those devices
that that information it's
telling you is not working.
And try to do it temporarily.
Some you may not ever
be able to support.
But there may be
some that you just
had written off that you could
revisit and address later on.
So again, you're
broadening your user base.
Next, pre-registration--
pre-registration an opportunity
for you to build hype.
This is you getting a page up
on the store that allows gamers
to A, know that your game
is coming before you're even
launched, gives them a little
bit of information about what
your game is about, and allows
them to click on the sign
up now button.
And they will then
get a notification
when your game launches.
It's a great way to see
and anticipate interest
so that you can have an
understanding of how--
if you are in tandem, in
closed beta or open beta--
it gives you an
opportunity to understand
how to maybe manage your UA
or your community-building
efforts.
This is a very
useful tool that way.
Then here are some
best practices
that we recommend in
terms of time frame.
So anywhere from
three to eight weeks--
I actually think the sweet
spot is about a month.
And give yourself a
chance to plan for this.
So pre-registration-- I'm going
to be speaking a little bit
more on this in a second.
This is actually not
available to everyone yet.
And I have a caveat for
that just for everyone
here in the room today.
But this is something you do
actually have to apply for,
much like early access.
It's a program.
It's a very specific
program that you
have to submit a request for.
So as I just alluded
to and teased on,
you will be receiving
some information
after this event via
email about those of you
who have not been part of
the Early Access program
around this.
You will actually be able to
apply for pre-registration
before we fully launch it
by the end of the year.
So keep your eye out for that.
This is a really cool
tool and opportunity
for you to be a
part of something
before we launch it to
the community at large.
OK.
Now let's head into post-launch.
So we'll be talking about
a couple things here.
We're going to be talking
about an insights page, which
is actually quite new as
a feature and very useful
as well as Play Instant.
And then I'll touch
very lightly on vitals.
This is actually something Ben
is going to talk a little bit
more about later.
OK.
So where are your
players coming from?
This is a question
that we would--
or a feature that we would
get requested on the regular
by developers big
and small, which is,
can you please
give us visibility
into how people are
finding us on the store?
Here you go.
This is how you
can check that out.
This breaks it down in
terms of search terms,
gives you a sense
of how people are
finding their way to your
game on the Play Store--
very useful tool.
Here's one of our
developers saying
that it's just been an
incredible insight for them
and has really allowed
them to figure out
how to optimize their
description pages
and how to leverage
search words as best
as possible to the
advantage of gamers
being able to find their
game on the Play Store.
So then how can you actually
get more users into your game?
We have Play Instant.
This is a piece of technology
that we've optimized for games,
specifically, just recently.
And this gives
gamers an opportunity
to play a small
segment of your game
without downloading anything.
Ostensibly, what it does is it
puts a try now button on there
once you've
implemented that API.
And this is a really great way
to break down that friction.
Especially if you
make paid games--
highly recommend this.
Here's some information around
what kind of conversion rates
we're seeing around user
acquisition for indie games,
specifically.
This is early days.
We just have game developers
starting to implement
this in the past few months.
So we're seeing anywhere
from 8% to 20% UA uplift.
And here's a bunch of ways that
you can actually funnel people
into your instant game.
So we have it
implemented into ads.
We have deep links.
There's a place on the
store, a collection that's
dedicated to this--
a lot of really great ways
to leverage this-- highly
recommend it.
Here's some more information
for you around instant games.
Give you guys a
chance take a picture.
All right.
Vitals-- Vitals is something
that will give you a snapshot
into the health of your game--
crash rates, wake
locks, things like that.
We want to be able to give
you that very quick picture
into how your game is performing
and how users are experiencing
your game and where you
can actually troubleshoot.
So Subway Surfers, who's
wildly popular game on Play,
they have been using it.
And just recently, they were
able to address a crash that
was coming out of nowhere and
allowed them to fix that really
quickly--
definitely take a look at that.
OK.
Whoo.
So there's the buffet for you.
That's everything we
quickly went through.
So some final thoughts--
I know that was a lot.
I know that was kind of
information overload.
But I would invite you
to really pick and choose
what's going to
work for your team.
Not everything will
apply, and that's OK.
It's really your choice into
what you would like to use.
But don't be afraid of change.
And don't be afraid
to try something new.
I know that the Console can be
quite overwhelming because we
have so many great tools.
And it's a lot.
Give it a try.
And here are some
more resources for you
for that really quick high
touch that I just gave you.
Here's where you can do a
deep dive into those features.
There's a lot to learn.
There's a bunch that
I didn't even mention.
So here are your resources.
And here's where
you can get updates.
Thanks, everyone.
Appreciate that.
[APPLAUSE]